لم تلبث الدبابات الاوكرانيه الخروج من
مستنقع الوحي الذي استمر طويلا واعاق
حركتها حتى اصطدمت بالغام روسيه مزروعه
بكثره فالروز قاموا بزرع الالغام في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بنسب تجعلها احد اكبر
حقول الالغام في العالم بحسب صحيفه ليموند
الفرنسيه وفقا للقوات الغربيه تغطي
الالغام المزروعه حاليا مساحه تقارب المئه
مربع اي ما يعادل سته اضعاف مساحه بلجيكا
لكن المصدر نفسه والنفع قيام الروس بزرع
كل هذه الالغام موضحا ان الاوكرانيين
وضعوا الكثير منها قبل الحرب لاسيام في
دومباس حيث يتقاتل الطرفان منذ عام 2014
الهجمات الاوكرانيه الهادفه للعثور على
نقطه ضعف في خط المواجهه الروسي لم تسر
كما ارادت كاف مع صعوبه تحقيق المكاسب
جنوب اوريكاف والتخلي عن دبابات غربيه بعد
تدميرها في ساحه المعركه كما يتعين على
كاف التغلب على مشكلتها الاساسيه اذا ما
ارادت التقدم على خط المواجهه والمتمثله
بنقص الطائرات المقاتله بينما تنتظر بفارغ
الصبر طائرات افسدت عشر من حلفائها
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات